what's up reject nation john here
we have a brand new suicide squad
the suicide squad trailer out today it's
april the first
at first i thought i was being fooled
that's apparently not the case we're
just getting the theatrical
exclusive trailer here on the internet
i'm excited to check this out the red
band trailer last week was very exciting
obviously greg and i did a reaction to
that
he will be back later on tonight and
probably will do his own reaction to
this but uh for right now
i am excited to check this out this
looks like a really fun time based off
what we've seen so far so
at this point i'm just like give me more
but as always if you could just remember
to like subscribe hit the notification
bell to get notified whenever one of our
videos
drops we would very much appreciate that
also shouts out to everyone who's joined
us on patreon it's a new month
best time to pledge if you're interested
in supporting the channel uh yeah let's
hop into this
super villains
sad souls and costumes wanting you to
think they're all
dark and deep what's the like
living life is a punchline damn fish are
friends not food
would be one blessed act of rebellion
wow
it's got a really different tone in its
entirety
you know the deal complete the mission
you get 10 years off your sentence
you failed to follow my class in any way
it's all strander the explosive device
in the basement cameo
these are your brothers and sisters for
the next few days oh
nice any questions and
yes that is your hand very good stallone
we're gonna die
learn that right after the first
reaction oh for god's sake
oh
god that's synth embellishments
i don't care how many men women and
children i need to kill to get it
whoa
ratcatcher looks cool man
oh here's the deal we failed a mission
you died
we find out any information you give us
is false you die
if we find out you have personalized
license plates you die what
nice nice
man man i wish i saw this trailer at
godzilla versus kong because i really
enjoyed this is a lot of fun i mean
obviously the suicide
squad looks like a blast anyway but what
i appreciate here is that they took a
slightly different tone with this
trailer it's a bit
more intense i feel like the first
trailer we saw last week has a bit more
of a rollicking
irreverent tone honing in on james
gunn's personality and sense of humor
and this certainly has that i mean there
are a lot of familiar shots from that
other trailer but
what i really appreciated about this was
just the way they yeah led with the tone
and the imagery and they really
established an atmosphere and part of
what i'm most excited to see with this
movie
is just how the atmosphere and tone all
comes together because from what james
gunn has said he wants each character to
kind of
exist in their own genre and kind of
bring their own film style along with
them so that's something i'm excited to
see
just for the movie but this trailer you
know had a more unified tone
in the sense that it seemed like it
wanted to hone in on
you know the heavier sides not in terms
of like
emotional depth or whatever but you know
the more badass and gritty
side of what they're doing because the
suicide squad is an edgy group and they
are going up against these hopeless
scenarios
and to that end actually i really
enjoyed the narration that starts off
this trailer kind of sounds like peter
capaldi's the thinker at least to me
but you know mocking the dark and you
know gritty
persona that a lot of these characters
want to put on and then hinting at the
redemption that probably truly drives
all of them in some way shape or form i
thought this trailer yeah did a nice job
of almost doing a reverse of the
previous suicide squad where the first
trailer was kind of dark and it had this
menacing tone and then it got lighter
and had more fun as
the trailers went on this uh seems like
yeah okay we're seeing another side of
the movies
aesthetic obviously you get new shots of
most of the team but you know the ones
that stood out to me the most were
especially like ratcatcher i thought her
shots were really cool
especially in the alleyway with all the
rats coming up around her i like the
little
sketches on her cell wall of course you
got john cena's peacemaker
shirtless looking sexy and also i like
that if anybody i feel like got
honed in on a bit more in this trailer
who has featured heavily in the last one
it's him because
i mean here he basically gets his
character log line
in that moment between him and rat
catcher where she says like i thought
you're supposed to be the peacemaker and
he says you know i
what is it i cherish peace with all my
heart i don't care how many men women
and children i need to kill
to get it like that just cracked me up
and it's making me all the more excited
to
see what level like i have a feeling
that james gunn
and john cena both are going to want to
just infuse that
character with the utmost irony even
getting to see him
with rick flagg and idris elba you know
bloodsport looking badass together just
as a trio
like in their casual friday clothes like
that was badass
uh you get more king shark here it's a
little finding nemo moment
a couple other things um pretty similar
to the previous trailer
it must be acknowledged though that uh
sylvester stallone we we caught that
news after that video had already been
edited but um i'm excited to see what he
brings to this movie because
it's just a voice roll for him a lot of
people have been clowning on it saying
like this is the most intelligible he's
ever sounded
um but i am excited to see what he
brings to a film
of this variety in that capacity where
he's just doing a
voiceover for a cg character you know
steve agee did the motion capture and
then he gets rewarded with his own
little bit part
you get a little moment in here of
mongal as well as alice braga i don't
remember them being as
much in the last trailer so it was nice
to at least get some hero shots here
especially
alice braga looking intense um and
whatever that dance sequence was
kind of reminded me of the previous you
know the suicide squad film where they
have it's like the best scene in the
movie you know where they
have that one actual scene in the bar
but that's deserted and that's towards
the end whereas this looks almost like
it's like a right before act two kind of
scene where it's like here's the last
hurrah
before we go on this you know impossible
uh task
but uh and then speaking of task uh you
got the task force x plane with the
ensemble getting on and uh that's
a thing about this trailer across the
board in this movie
i feel like the previous suicide squad
not to keep harping on that but
you know it's supposed to be an ensemble
of colorful characters and it more
felt like just a bunch of colorful
characters next to each other whereas
throughout this trailer it really does
feel like the ensemble is going to be
just synthesized into the tone and into
the experience of the movie
you get some detachable kid finally in
this trailer
confirming basically his place is the
you know
newly rendered version of arm falloff
boy uh that
probably was my favorite surprise of
this trailer
obviously gonna be some kind of meme i
feel like the suicide squad
it's been said of the comics and you can
just kind of tell by
what it is that you know certain
villains who seem
especially silly we'll probably get some
badass moments you know and certain
heroes who seem like they should be
especially badass will probably get some
subversive womp
moments yeah that was an instance where
i'm like i don't know man
like as silly as this guy is maybe his
appearance will be pretty badass
um i'm speaking about ass bloodsport the
gun at the end i thought that was really
awesome looking everybody really seems
like even down to harley in characters
like that like
they suit the scope and scale of the
mission at hand and
i don't even know that much about the
mission at hand it's clear there's going
to be like a kaiju
but there's also going to be militias
and stuff like it it seems much better
conceived as of the team
overall you get a couple more shots of
weasel everyone looking weird at weasel
uh you get boomerang with an actual
moment of badassery which is just
you know good for jai courtney anytime
jai courtney can get a win i'm here for
it polka dot man
is uh someone i'm really excited to see
in this movie i think david das malkian
is a very fun
character actor who's been holding it
down for so many years and i think now
people are finally gonna start learning
his name i was trying to slow the shot
down where he's throwing the actual
polka dots
it seems like we got a little bit more
of that here the character as it's been
pitched to me is supposed to have
sort of different powers with each
different color right um
so i was curious as to whether we were
only seeing instances of the ones that
explode or if they're all just going to
be bombs but uh either way
like the look of that character the even
little comedic beats that he got in this
trailer i thought were really fun and
starro i like the approach they're
taking
because you know there's like a little
image in the last trailer you can see
over steve agee's shoulder where you can
tell it's
a starfish but even so i like that here
the only like they added a couple new
shots and it's basically like
the foot to like one very small specific
but also you know giant dude to the
scale piece
um so i like that they aren't going okay
here just have all the sorrow shots
while they're also going no but he's
here but that's not the point and it
doesn't feel again like
a movie blowing its load too soon or
showing you doomsday and the key to the
you know salvation that they'll team up
over or whatever you know it seems like
all just part of this
weird and ever exploding situation so
i'm here for it man this movie looks
like a lot of fun and
especially with the tones of these two
trailers combined
i'm really excited for the actual just
overall film that james gunn and company
are going to deliver us because again
it's communicating to me that they found
a way to really bring you all the fun
and pulp that you want
while also giving you a movie that has
some thought put into
it and some flow and some actual stakes
as much fun and as crazy as all this
stuff isn't as fantastical as it is it
also does feel kind of like a 70s war
movie and an 80s sort of exploitation
film
so uh kudos for that leave me your
thoughts down below is there anything i
missed that i didn't pick up on you
holler at me call me an idiot or a fake
nerd or whatever
or enlighten me that's how i like to
look at it but anyway i've rambled
enough appreciate you joining me
remember to like and subscribe hit that
notification bell and i'll see you for
the next one
cheers also a quick shout out to alex
biewer or or bivar i'm not 100 sure
to say your name but you joined for our
bts and deleted takes at the end of
march
it's april the 1st but it's april fool's
day so uh i'm honoring you today much
love thank you for joining us and i will
see you soon